the spidey debacle what do you make of
it what happens to happy in May now what
happens to happy omit well I guess happy
single again after all that time took
ten years for him to get into a good
relationship yeah uh you know it's still
early days and I'm as a fan I'm
cautiously hopeful that something will
come together because I think all the
fans want to see those characters
together I don't mean happy and May I
mean I mean Spidey with with the MCU
so you know it's still early days and
things you know it you don't know is
what you read isn't always indicative of
where things are right now so I
hopefully I'll find out more while I'm
here but uh but as a fan I'm hopeful
that you know cautiously optimistic
holding out hope that this isn't the
final chapter of that story how does it
feel to be a Disney Legend I think it's
fun to be here at d23 at all and then to
be on stage with people like Robert
Downey jr. who I came up with in the in
the Marvel world is really is really
quite I'm very grateful for it it's it's
really nice to be alongside if not just
the people on stage today but all the
pioneers of animation and the
storytelling of all the you know
innovators and Technology theme parks I
think it's a tremendous impact if you
look at what Disney started and how this
influenced all other Studios and theme
parks and animation it's a it's quite an
honor to be alongside of like the nine
old men and the people who who were the
pioneers of that craft
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]